[Music]
if I mean if there is a theme to the
show that I do it's it's how can we live
more authentically how can we you know
create a life for ourselves that is more
in tune with our natural blueprint and
that's a journey of discovery that will
last you your entire life but the more
that you can kind of connect with that
and explore that not at the behest of
leaving your job necessarily but just to
bring more of that experience into your
life I think will gird it with meaning
and will lead you on an incredible you
know journey of discovery of yourself
and I think will brighten the the pallet
of the world I think historically the
word creative or creativity isn't
necessarily pejorative but it's
exclusionary people either identify with
that or they don't or they're scared of
it and in truth it is it is part and
parcel of what makes us human it is a
universal aspect of the condition of
being you know in in one of these bodies
and let's do let's deconstruct that wall
of fear that is preventing you from
trying something new and the truth is
all those excuses are now of no merit in
a time and a day when almost everybody
as a smartphone our culture has shifted
and changed the gatekeepers are gone the
tools of creativity are more accessible
than ever there's a more there's a
democratization of this universe that
didn't exist back then and whether that
means quitting your job to be an artist
or just finding a hobby or like you know
being intentional about the images you
put on Instagram these are all aspects
of creativity in everyday life or
everybody no matter who you are
[Music]